Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors, along with Michelle Hamburger. And we're going to talk about
So in our members minute three we spoke about the knife and
It's correlation to helping the body with chemotherapy and how really the the fact that the knife is not an oxidizing
Agent or a therapy is why it is not
Indicated when someone's doing chemo, but that brings up a really great question of if somebody is not to be taking
Antioxidants when they're doing chemotherapy. Well, what does that consist of?
Am I not allowed to eat blueberries? Am I not allowed to eat certain foods that have
High high antioxidant levels or take my supplements?
There are some doctors that have said you need to go off of everything if you're going to do chemo
We actually had a patient recently who's oncologist
Told her to go off of every single supplement that she was on if she was going to do chemo
So where is that balance between can I eat foods that contain antioxidants?
May I still continue to take my supplements and then where do we draw that line where you probably shouldn't
Consume or have that uptake of antioxidants to allow the chemo to do its job
Well, certainly we legally have to draw the line that you have to make the decision on your own
We can't tell you to do something that your oncologist is telling you not to do
Because then that would be practicing medicine and going against them. So we have to throw that little legal caveat in there
Very true, but it does make sense what they're saying
We don't want to flood the body with super high dose antioxidants
If we are giving the body an oxidizing agent
aka chemotherapy to kill the cancer
So there are different
Thoughts here. So just understand there are people in the alternative perspectives that say fully on that
You need to flood the body with high dose antioxidants. We're going to give high dose
Alpha-lopeic acid. We're going to give high dose of vitamin C and
and
Different nutrients that are going to protect the body cells and you have to do that even more
So if you're going to do chemotherapy that is a poison we got to protect your body cells
I don't
That's how they agree with that
I
Fall more into the middle of the camp and say that yes, I think it's wise not to while you're doing chemotherapy
We don't want to give high dose anti-oxidant
nutrients
To because then we would affect if they actually are working
They're actually they could actually be protecting cancer cells from the chemo therapy
I don't think that's a wise thing to do. I think if you're going to do chemotherapy
You want the chemotherapy to work on those cancer cells
So I think we should drop down
Any high dose antioxidants in truth. We don't really we don't have any of our patients on high dose antioxidants anyhow
So but I know a lot of people are doing high dose you know IV drips of ALA or
They're taking a lot of
different antioxidants that could affect the
lot of the livelihood of a cancer cell and
I think it's wise to not do that now take getting antioxidants in your foods
That's where I fall into the category of I think you should be still consuming
Foods that have antioxidants in them. So
That's where can you still do juicing while you're doing chemo? My belief is yes, you can
Can you still eat a good diet while you're doing chemo? Well, of course you can
So I think that's very important. I put up a slide here on how antioxidants work
You have three radicals in your body
That are caused from oxidizing agents
So this is what chemotherapy is really acting as
Uh, and antioxidants bind to those free radicals basically to preserve the cell and
uh, if I'm going to take
Uh, high dose alpha-lopeic acid while I'm doing chemotherapy theoretically and I think in reality
We could be preserving a cancer cell. So that's where I'd say go down on the
Supplements that are antioxidants for the first 48 hours that you are doing chemotherapy or 48 hours post chemotherapy
Similar to how we would wait
After chemotherapy to start a detoxification process and then after the 48 hours after the administration of chemotherapy
Then certainly go back on the antioxidants to help preserve your
Your cells and it and I say that 48 hours because they're
Has been data out there
That shows that chemotherapy really acts on the cancer cells
Mainly within the first 48 hours of administration
Um, and there that can be disputed. I understand that but we do want to preserve healthy cells
Um, and we have to walk that balance. So certainly you have to make your own decision here
Certainly we don't want to go against what your oncologist is saying
However, they're taking an approach that they're taught through pharmaceutical
Uh, measures not necessarily really looking at the research
You have to do your own research and I would say don't take my word dogmanically
And don't take anybody's word dogmanically do your own research and come to your old conclusions with this
But you have to have a balance
Sounds good. All right. Thanks very much